so hey that's a lot of nerdfighters and
this is Hosny Mubarak that's called a
transition Hank it's a skill of
professional writers Hank Mubarak may or
may not be a nerdfighter although I
suspect he isn't because he doesn't seem
to love the internet but he is the 82
year old dictator of Egypt and as you
might have heard on the news his 30-year
rule is in peril and lots of
nerdfighters have asked me to make a
video about Egypt so I'm gonna okay so
Egypt is a northern African nation of 80
million people primary language Arabic
90% Muslim 10% Christian it used to be
kind of the center of the world then was
part of a bunch of empires let's just
skip end in 1979 okay so it's 1979 and
the president of Egypt Anwar Sadat sends
a peace treaty with Israel thereby
establishing Egypt at least in the mind
of the West is the kind of politically
and militaristic aliy moderate Arab
state two years later in 1981 Anwar
Sadat is assassinated by Islamists his
vice president Hosni Mubarak gets shot
in the hand but survived so
congratulations hosny you get to be
president of Egypt that was the first
time he survived an assassination
attempt Mubarak has since survived five
more assassination attempts which is the
kind of thing that can make you super
super paranoid and in fact has made him
super super paranoid anyway despite the
considerable dangers of the gig Hosny
Mubarak seems to really like being
president of Egypt because his three
main political positions are number one
I Hosny Mubarak should be the president
of Egypt number two there should be no
freedom of press and no Islamist
political parties in fact no political
parties at all really because I Hosny
Mubarak should remain the president of
Egypt and number three people who
disagree with number one or number two
should go to jail in fact and even
before all these protests start in the
last week there are more than 10,000
political prisoners in jail in Egypt
which is a lot but like a drop in the
bucket compared to say China and we're
not exactly fomenting revolution in
China right now unless you define
fomenting as purchasing and revolution
as iPods so everybody's always been kind
of friends with him both in the Arab
world and in the West everybody's like
oh it's Mubarak he could be worse but
then in the beginning of 2011 Egypt's
neighbor Tunisia suddenly and
unexpectedly got rid of their dictator
and after seeing what happened in
Tunisia people in Egypt were like hey
I'm pissed off too I'm pissed off about
not having freedom of speech and about
the secret police and about rising food
prices remember
French Revolution Hank rising food
prices I'm telling you Hank if you ever
become a dictator keep your eye on the
price of food so on January 25th 2011
people hit the streets now initially the
police which are often seen as a force
of terror in Egypt were attacking
protesters and throwing them in jail and
torturing them and then Mubarak resorts
to all the typical old-fashioned
dictators stuff like turning off all the
phones and turning off the internet and
none of it really works so finally
Mubarak played his last card he sent the
army out onto the streets of Cairo which
totally backfired it backfired because
all male Egyptians have to serve some
time in the army so the army is seen as
an extension of the citizenry and that's
why you see all these protesters
climbing on top of Tanks and shaking
hands with the guys inside the tanks and
like scrawling anti-mubarak graffiti on
Mubarak's tanks and it's looking like
Mubarak is going to have to make his
graceful exit and that is when the hard
work will begin there's a lot of romance
in revolution Hank we all know this
right I can't help myself I love a good
revolution I love men and women standing
up to Authority risking their lives for
their country but that's exactly what
happened in the French Revolution which
ended up being a massive Oh disaster oh
that's not French in fact anq it must be
noted that revolution does not have a
particularly good track record so Hank
right now the story of Egypt's political
situation is really shiny and
interesting that's why we're all paying
attention to it
and in a few months it won't be so shiny
there will be something new shiny
hopefully the invention of puppy-sized
elephants and I will name him Louis and
teach him to poop outside and he and
Willie will play together in the snow
and it will be so beaut are we talking
about something Egypt right so hopefully
Egypt will make the difficult transition
to a real democracy and the way that we
can support that is to continue to pay
attention to their story even when it's
not so shiny anymore okay thank you for
listening to me talk about Egypt as
reward I will do a question Tuesday on
Friday please leave your questions and
comments
babies crying so I got to go Hank I'll
see you on Wednesday